So you're all wondering what your
papers,
no doubt they are.
Mark do I have no,
um,
I'll leave the papers outside my office
on my bench.
Hopefully tomorrow morning.
I am struck hypothesis about the
relative value of things including the
self and others.
But this might not make sense.
It's pretty complicated idea.
What pages are going,
don't you,
don't you have that memorized?
Yeah.
Anyways,
they're simpler.
One 31 30 middle of the first power.
Oh yes,
yes.
Okay.
So we haven't,
well,
things get complex here rapidly,
so that's what we're going to do at
first a little bit is do some brick
capitulation so everyone knows where we
are before we go somewhere new.
I'm
trying to convince you of the notion
that
when we model our experience,
we're coming up with two different kinds
of models,
which are usually conflated.
We don't,
we're not really clear about the
difference between,
one is a map of fact and that map it's
construction has construction of that
map has been formalized as the
scientific endeavor.
The map itself is the sum total of
scientific knowledge.
Science is how we generate our knowledge
about.
Fact,
and I'm sort of in that fact,
is
consensually apprehensible phenomena or
its pattern of transformation because
science is not only interested in
clarifying the nature of objects,
who also wants to be able to tell how
one object,
how an object changes into something
else over time.
As Einstein pointed out in the quote
that I
provided by him
were generally used to regarding that
sort of phenomenon has real
Einstein wasn't a philosopher of
science.
I think it was obviously a great
scientist and at the very least his
quotation who talks about the
consensually validatable properties or
things describes the manner in which
people conduct science under normal
circumstances.
That's what we think we're doing and
there's a different kind of map and
that's a map not of
fact about things,
but about what those things signify for
behavior.
And I mean for motor output,
what they signify for what you should do
when you're around them,
when you encounter them.
And we don't really understand that map
very well.
We don't naturally,
I don't think we naturally think of it
as sort of a separable phenomena.
It strikes me that you can make a
reasonable case that it's actually the
type of map that proceeded the formal
development of of science because we
like animals are primarily concerned
with how to act rather than with what is
in fact.
And if you understand that,
then you can answer some questions that
otherwise remain somewhat mysterious.
For example,
how do you know when you're right about
something and a fundamental basis,
you're never bragged about anything
because wherever you look,
there's an infinite number of mysteries,
at least from the factions.
They tend not to disturb you.
And it is the case that we have placed
implicit faith in the notion that we
know things and that what we know is
sufficient even though we know that what
we know isn't sufficient in the final
analysis,
not only is it wrong,
but it's sufficiently wrong.
So that over the course of centuries and
transformed itself into something that's
often even unrecognizable but it,
but it still strikes us as knowledge and
that's because I think we think we know
something when acting on that knowledge.
We produce results that we want and
that's sufficient.
If you get from point a to point b using
procedures,
see,
then you're convinced that you're right
because that's it.
That's right enough and that's our
criteria.
Antonio Damacio for example,
he just wrote a new book called
Descartes' error,
big carts era being,
I think therefore I am.
It makes,
it was pointing out that people with
damage to the prefrontal cortex start to
lose the ability to make decisions,
to decide between trivial things like
when or to decide to reveal things.
Not necessarily just between like when
you throw out old newspapers or which
restaurant to to
you don't sum total all the facts about
given a given restaurant and everything
you can think about it and then contrast
that restaurant with all conceivable
restaurants.
When you go up to eat the process,
it's pretty automatic and amaze.
You aren't used it.
We do it by recourse to emotion.
The frontal lobes help us determine what
our emotions are.
Say,
define it.
As a consequence.
We can eliminate vast swaths of material
that would just sort of clog up our
cognitive faculties otherwise.
But the thing is,
okay,
knowing a little bit about how stories
work,
how are we paused?
Our ideal futures and how we move
towards them instantly gives you some
insight into how it is that we
determined that we actually know
something and when we say we know
something we basically need,
our knowledge is sufficient to get us
from point a to point b.
And that's enough.
That's that that keeps us in the
expected role.
It keeps our emotions regulated.
And I would say that the purpose of
knowledge is to regulate emotion.
That's what you have at four so I mean
you're always engaged in the endeavor to
increase.
Well,
this is right.
This is kind of a behaviorist way of
looking at it,
but it's sufficiently accurate so that
it's useful.
You want to live in a world where
there's lots of hope for the future,
but where you're satisfied all in all,
or at least you're working to maximize
your satisfaction,
you also want to avoid anxiety to the
degree that that's possible within the
context of maximizing hope and
satisfaction.
And also this same goes for pain.
They're always trying to regulate your
emotions.
In fact,
the reason we modify the external world
is to regulate our emotions.
We tend to think that emotional
regulation is actually a psychological
processes,
right?
Calm down,
bring your cell phone under control.
That's only true in the most trivial of
circumstances almost all the time.
What we do to regulate our emotions is
to change things around us with our
behavior so that we're satisfied more or
less with the manner in which our limbic
system is conducting itself,
motivates our behavior.
It kind of knowledge that you have that
enables you to act so what you want
appears,
I'd call that.
That's what we're,
that's what we're contrast on this
class.
I guess the domain of pathology,
that's how wisdom is transmitted,
not factual knowledge.
Wisdom is how to act so that you get no
one only.
It's not really so that you get what you
want it.
That's a really simple way of looking at
it and saw that your emotions remain
regulated,
stable over time in a situation and it's
primarily composed of others who are
doing the same thing.
Cool.
Who all have to act,
including you in a manner so that that
stable regulation is flexible enough so
that it can update itself wouldn't
necessarily across time.
So there's a lot of constraints that
have to be satisfied in order for your
solution to the regulation of your
emotions to be considered optimal.
When you talk about how to act in any
given situation,
it sounds as if I only think of social
situations
I'm talking about because most of our
environment is a social environment.
Most of what I consider my environment
is is you and everyone else that I can
offer.
You want to know how to ask as
well.
I would,
I would say look,
okay,
that's a perfectly reasonable question.
I would say wisdom is an abstraction of
behavioral low,
so I wouldn't say necessarily,
but knowing how to open up the box of
the computer and fix whatever particular
electronic park happens to be followed
up constitutes wisdom.
But I would say that,
but usually what happens if your
computer falls up is that you don't know
what to do.
But what you do know is how to figure
out what to do.
And basically what you do when you're
trying to fix a computer
based on the presumption that you can
fix it,
which is like the presumption that leads
the whole behavior is to hold everything
constant and very one things,
right?
You engage in a process of trial and
error list.
That's the bonding towards solving the
problem.
And I would say being able to engage in
the maneuvers that allows you to
generate the specific answer to the
problem.
That's pretty much akin to wisdom.
So,
so I mean that's the computer,
it's a little different because the
computers,
the computer computer is a bit peculiar
though because it's an artificial
environment in that it's it,
it isn't something I've infinite to
flexibly in a sense,
at least at the level at which you want
to interact with it.
It's a finite domain.
So a real standard set of problem
solving techniques can be applied to it.
So yeah.
Yeah.
So the computer,
while the computer is probably the only
part of the University of actually who
works exactly as you predicted would
from the scientific perspective.
So we will,
if there's not a lot of them remaining
mystery.
So it was just the mirror you freeze.
Yeah.
The first time.
Especially if you're doing something at
court and then you sort of fee then
don't you need a strategy to allay your
anxieties,
which is calling the help number.
That's recourse to authority.
Yeah,
that's a comfort mode and promise all.
That's true.
I would say I would still,
I would say that the process of
generating solutions is more akin to
wisdom than the actual,
their knowledge of any specific
solution.
And that sort of without actually serves
as a good introduction to the internal
things we want to talk about today.
Okay.
So anyways,
so I was,
I was summing up reiterating the
distinction between the domain of myth
and the domain of science making the
additional point and that mythology is
both,
it's the story we tell about our wisdom
and it's also our means of transmitting
it basically in the same can be said
about narratives in any sort of specific
examples of more general myths.
So,
um,
okay.
Well then,
okay,
the next question that pops up is before
the second,
the next question that pops up,
isn't it?
Well,
if you can,
you can conceive of the world as a
collection of objects and that
transformation,
but we're not doing that.
We're conceiving of the world as a place
to conduct action in.
And so then the next question is,
if you conceive of the world as a place
in which to act,
what's the structure of it?
And it's strikes me that you can
determine the structure by contrast and
myths and seeing,
picking out their commonalities.
There's a bit more to it than that
because there are creationists and
creation myths explicitly statement.
What you're dealing with is a
description of the genesis of the world.
So it's also a natural natural field of
inquiry for mythologies.
And what I have been attempting to
describe,
it's my summary,
I guess,
of these various myths and the world
that they portrayed and the mythological
world has basically has three
constituent elements.
You could say four.
There's the chaos that precedes the
construction of anything and that's
representative as their gross has the
dragon that eats its own tail as the
winged serpent and the winged serpent is
similar [inaudible] a creature of
spirit,
and that was the sky as the masculine
world and a creature of matter.
That's the feminine world.
Masculine world has two aspects.
One is more akin to spirit speaking
traditionally,
and the other is more akin to the
patriarchal structure to the great
father.
The masculine world is both the process
by which knowledge is generated and that
dual image.
That's why,
for example,
in the Egyptian mythology that surrounds
the Pharaoh,
the live pharaoh is simultaneously
ocirus and horace.
Oh,
seriousness of Syrah stands for the
state as a historical entity.
That's one way of looking at it.
And Horace stands for the process by
which that state is updated and
generated and the live pharaoh in so far
as he's doing his job is both the dead
steak and the process by which the dead
state is regenerating.
Remember when horace goes to the
underworld to find his father was blind
and living a sort of a semi vegetative
life.
After he,
after you become seth,
by the way he gives him,
he gives him his eye and that brings
them back up the surface,
so to speak.
Well,
now you know what that story means.
That's a very common story.
That's the myth of the rebirth.
That became basically part of the hero's
journey.
He saw a little bit of that echoed in
Nokia.
Really kind of a peculiar place to find
those serious and chorus.
I think if you think about,
it's kind of hard to figure out how that
might have come about unless you're
willing to entertain them.
Like one consistent,
some of these images we're going to do
get saved and passed around and all
sorts of bizarre forums.
So Remember Pinocchio to be the true
hero,
which meant to be real,
which meant to be born again.
He no,
he not only had to go into the belly of
the whale,
that's the unknown your boroughs,
but he had to save his father,
couldn't just abandon it and save
himself.
He had to bring the culture along with.
It does,
that's a really potent story if you
think,
and obviously true sincere culture
protects you to abandon it or to him to
fail it when it needs help,
so to speak means to turn your back on
precisely the thing that protects you
from things that you understand so
poorly that you don't even know they're
there.
So I remember in the hall,
but this isn't the Hobbit,
it was very popping in the 60s I mean
it's a myth.
The hobbit saw live in a kingdom that
it's threatened by vague forces from
outside.
Their little people,
among them are large people who they
call the striders and the strategy has
looked like vagabonds and they patrol
the perimeter of the hobbits kingdom,
sort of unknown to the hobbits,
but they're the mythical ancestors,
like the hobbits have a fair amount of
contempt for them actually thinking of
them as traps,
but they're actually the forces that
keep the unknown.
The vague.
I've known at bay so thoroughly that the
hobbits don't even know that it's there
really well.
That's the position that we're in.
I mean,
that's one of the things I want to
convince you out,
so to speak.
In the commerce of this class,
there's the remnants of the old kingdom,
right?
And the remnants of the old kingdom.
Absolutely.
They're the ancestral powers.
There are lots of cultures worship their
ancestors,
erect stone monuments to the for
example,
so they don't forget all the ancestors.
It's easy for ancestors as well to turn
into gods.
In fact,
that's what ancestors do over time is
they turned into cost and we added
points out,
for example,
that among our key people,
and that in this context means people
without a written tradition,
when people who only transmit
information orally,
historical events get transformed into
mythological events when they pass out
of living memory,
which is to say when the last person
who's alive that remembers the event
dies,
then that event is immediately in a
sense remembered as an event that took
place in the unspecified time that
preceded the construction of the world.
And I think the reason for that is is
that you don't want to burden your
memory.
All you want to remember is the things
that are important and we're talking
about remembering things say over the
course of 25,000 years,
all of the unnecessary information that
gets burdened away and all that's left
is the core pattern of information that
any historical event worthy of note
necessarily contains when we consider an
event historical.
This is part of the reason why history,
so he sits on the boundary between
pathology and science in a sense to
consider an event worthy of historical
note necessarily has to contain elements
of your own mythology because otherwise
if it didn't contain an element of
conquering the unknown,
for example,
we would never regarded as sufficiently
valuable to even relegate to the domain
of necessary fat.
This is troublesome for history because
study of history is supposed to be
formalized into Sam's.
This is a big,
big problem in history of generals.
Historical stories are told from within
cultural perspectives.
It would be awesome example of that is
how you conceive of Columbus if you're a
European side.
Traditional York painting the standards
story four years ago was no,
Columbus was a hero conquered new
territory.
Columbus.
By the way,
this is a historical fact.
Columbus was in fact looking for
paradise when he went out on his
missions.
That was his express motivation.
He thought like many people of his time,
that the paradise described in the Old
Testament was an actual location on
earth that perhaps could still be found
somewhere.
Columbus hypothesized that paradise
could be found in the domain of the
unknown.
You never,
the medieval maps,
there's vaguely defined territory with
terrible monsters surrounding and Love
Columbus presume that paradise could be
found in the domain of the unknown and
now anyway,
conflating a mythological viewpoint of
the world with with the actual word,
but it's very peculiar because of
course,
even from the perspective of pure fact,
even though we wouldn't regard that has
an accurate description,
it is the case from the mythological
perspective that paradise still does
reside out in the unknown because the
only way you can ever get there is to
explore it and constantly regenerate new
information.
So in a sense he was wrong,
but he was also,
he was also right.
It depends on your framework
interpretation.
Anyways,
the problem is that reading of Columbus
is necessarily in contrast with the
reading of Columbus,
for example,
that might appear more natural to the
North American Indians.
So it's hard to,
it's hard to figure out the appropriate
historical perspective or two.
And if you,
if you separate all the facts from the
fiction so to speak,
the problem then becomes that the facts
are dead and you end up in the position
of having to memorize endless states and
lists of places that will learn,
embed themselves in your memory because
they have no significance for behavioral
output,
which is what students need when they
say,
why is it necessary for us to learn
this?
And this dude is then say,
for me,
this holds no intrinsic interest.
And they're saying because my limbic
system is intelligent enough to
discriminate between information that it
has the potential to impact my behavior
or the way I framed the world and that
which does not have that capacity.
And since I only have a limited time,
I should probably attend to what's
important.
And generally what we mean by what is
important is what will actually change
the way we conduct ourselves if we learn
it.
This is something that we seem to have
either never quite figured out or
forgotten or I think much of education
is that the purpose of education,
the purpose of facts even is to aid the
generation of wisdom and if it fails to
produce that end then it's useless.
It's worse than useless,
it's just,
it's,
it's noise,
that's all.
So we don't have a formalized method for
the transmission of wisdom and we've
forgotten the domain in which it's
transmitted and we know a lot about fact
is that another person's worst
nightmare,
nightmare.
And different cultures share different
stories to such an extent that like one
person can be seen as like
more cultures constantly at war,
each other every day has it.
The whole thing has become so did that
we all recognize like one basic,
well I guess it depends on what you mean
by everyday.
I mean there's been more than 150 wars
since the end of World War II.
So that's mean which we consider in a,
in a sentence the last war.
Well with certain exceptions,
Obviously Korea and Vietnam,
certainly large
conflicts of the sword you described do
occur all the time.
And the other thing that needs to be
taken into consideration is that wars
can be conducted at many levels of
analysis.
It's like one of the,
one of the
advantages to being able to abstract
ideas is that we can have a war that
proceeds at the abstract,
that domain without unnecessarily
unnecessarily degenerating into physical
conflict,
which means that there's at least the
possibility that if you hold one in
theological stamps,
which means that you ascribe one meaning
to an object and I ascribe another
meeting that we can discuss it and fight
and conduct the war in words.
And as a consequence come to an
agreement,
which I suppose might be considered the
construction of annuity Ologie or doing
the film without necessarily having to
allow the process to cascade back down
behavior where the we're forced
determines.
Okay,
so what is peace then?
Like?
Like what is like,
it's just like a lack of social
aggression like out now battling it out
with this.
Is that like are just like just
contending ourselves,
didn't speak verbally at each other's
throats?
Is that the best we can do?
Right.
Well that,
well that's a perfectly reasonable
question.
I guess the question is what attitude
most most essentially characterizes the
attitude piece.
I saw one time when I was in Montreal
and I saw a 19 year old guy standing on
the street in an outdoor shopping mall.
Here's a big character,
tough luck.
You had a punk haircut and a leather
jacket and he was standing on the corner
holding your pink shopping bag full of
something.
I thought,
all right,
sorry.
He looked somewhat in the RV and I
suspect that he thought he looked the
same way holding this up
and I thought you look at someone like
that will be aware of their capacity for
aggression on the outside of their skin
where everyone can see it,
but there's no domain for its proper
expression.
So people in that situation ended up
doing things that are essentially
inserted,
like working in seven 11 for example,
standing up at quarter of a shopping
mall to pink shopping bag in there.
Harrison,
what are the things that you might
wonder under those circumstances is
that,
is there any way that you could
construct an attitude towards peace that
was sufficiently difficult and
aggressive that it would satisfy someone
who's in that particular position?
We tend to think of on that
as a state,
as a default condition I suppose as the
state then rains when nothing is
necessarily happening.
Strikes me that in order to make peace
and attractive proposition has to be
demonstrated incontrovertibly in a sense
that it's actually a more dangerous and
interesting answer.
War War I think I understand now
different perceptions of wisdom meaning
like different ways of regulating
emotions and the fact that cultures
regulate emotions know differently than
many of the societies.
Yeah.
Maintain order and yeah,
they like the motions like I,
cause I was thinking about wisdom and I
was like,
well that's kind of a subjective term.
Like you may,
I think of your wisdom is dysfunctional,
you know?
Whereas I think the mind is functioning,
handle things to regulate your emotions.
It may not be the truth,
the truth,
so it's an war being fought because of
different in those are placed here.
Right,
and that's why.
Right.
Okay.
I mean you can,
you can push the argument down a level
of analysis even insane which basically
the point of this particular quote that
our maps determined in the meaning of
objects in our,
in our spiritual field,
so to speak,
and wherever there's a difference.
Wherever you presume that this object
has a different implication for your
behavior,
what can I do or for our mutual
love what's in its presence.
Then there's an unknown right there and
there's also instant room for conflict
because you can only do well.
This is not always the case,
but it's frequently the case that only
one set of behavioral outputs can be
manifested in any particular situation.
That's certainly the case for an
individual.
I mean that's why you have to solve your
problems is because you can't do two
things at the same time.
You can only do one thing.
So
this is going back only long ways.
I'm curious that you
tend to refer to the domain of methods,
the men that we have forgotten because
it seems to me that if we were to know
it,
if we were to know it now,
we would know it in a way that we never
could have known it before.
Yes,
it's not exactly,
I forgotten there was that.
It was now in a home.
It was the whole way in which we now
know was built out of that and that's
behind.
So it didn't do it because I never know
how well I think that's,
that's a reasonable,
but that's a perfectly reasonable way of
looking at it.
Except I would say that there's one more
twist to that,
Matt,
is that at a defined time in the past,
and I would say starting approximately
500 years ago,
when the scientific methodology really
came into its own,
we made the mis attribution that we did
in fact understand what we had never
understood.
And not only that we didn't understand
it,
but we understood it thoroughly enough
to know that it was no longer a valid
form of knowledge and that we could
safely discarded as superstition or as,
as a primitive form of science and move
into the future.
But it seems to me that there was never
a point at which we said,
well,
we said what we were doing and Ben was
silliness.
And what we were doing now is the,
is the road,
uh,
to understand that.
All right,
thank you.
I have a real problem.
Jerry Hagen
and I borrow
your class.
Go down.
It's just
objects.
You see as soon as you mess with the
object,
because it's mapped in accordance with
this mythological structure,
you instantly start to wreak havoc on
the whole structure that determines the
appropriate,
the appropriate behavior of books.
So we know already what that structure
inhibits.
It inhibits,
well,
one of the things that inhibits his
anxiety.
One of the things that you may have
found doing,
by the way,
when this unexpected occurrence,
the roads was doing something that
children do when they don't know what to
do,
which is called referencing.
Oh,
if a child does something unexpected,
say it drops a glass of milk on the
floor,
the first thing it will do is look at
its mother or whichever it all happens
to be present because the unexpected is
just revealed itself,
which is to say that an event that
occurred contrary to plan emerge,
it's indeterminate insignificance,
although it evokes anxiety.
The fastest way to get rid of the
anxieties to reference,
which is that you look at your parent
and you watch your parents actions and
the parent's actions determined the
actual significance of the event,
thus reducing its infinite significant.
So to speak to a definable category.
And what you have to understand for
children is,
and I think this is true anyways,
even if the parent is angry,
the definite anger is better than the in
determinant significance.
Well,
children,
that's why children prefer order to
chaos even if it's relatively straight
door.
Anyways,
um,
set of questions.
So you're dying dominance hierarchy.
I don't know.
I don't understand what we were talking
about.
You're talking about the,
the,
um,
the meaning of the projector to you as
opposed to the meaning of the projector
to him that had a conflict.
Absolutely.
No,
but not only the meaning of the
projectors so to speak,
but everything that the,
the dispute implied say about relative
importance of pursuit.
Like in an institution like this,
there's at least a,
um,
what would you say?
There's at least the theory of equality
of access to certain things at,
at any number of levels,
like access to audio,
visual equipment.
You know,
the fact that someone's been around here
longer than me,
for example,
it has no bearing in theory and in
actuality under almost all conditions on
their access to things like audio,
visual equipment.
So when being comes in here and says,
you know,
despite what you're doing and the fact
that you followed the rules,
someone who's senior so to speak,
wants this and that's that.
So there's a lot of information in that
sort of interaction about relative
importance and not just relative
importance off of that projector,
but of the parties who were engaged in
negotiation for the projector anyways,
with regards to referencing,
I was wondering like you can think back
about your own reactions.
Do you look around,
did you look around when that was going
on to see how other people responded and
because that's,
that's a way of coming up.
That's a way of trying to instantly
acquire consensus.
It's right.
What the Hell's going on?
I don't know.
Maybe some of these other people know
all look at them.
I can tell by their facial reactions are
their patterns of behavior,
what this event might signify.
That's exploratory behavior.
You're exploring the environment but the
environment,
many cases is composed of other people.
In fact,
the most important part of the
environment is composed of other people
and when we have a map of the
environment who were mapping is other
people in relationship to herself and
and vice versa.
So that's referencing you poached.
You pushed him like you wouldn't back
up.
I thought,
I mean you could have considered again
in the fight as well.
That seems like that's the other,
that's the other purpose or the
demonstration is that
if I have a map and you have a map and
they and they conflict with regards to a
particular object,
then which happens very frequently.
Then one of the things that's
interesting to do is to consider the
options for eliminating the conflict.
One option is to eliminate one of the
conflicting parties.
I mean that's an option that's very
helpful.
Commonly held when you buy.
What people generally do is they start
to negotiate verbally,
which basically means that they're using
their verbal behavior to put their plan
back into action to get what they want
and as that's blocked saying it doesn't
work,
more and more emotion builds up and
other strategies but are sort of lower
on the access hierarchy.
Get thrown into play culminate possible.
Possibly.
What I wanted to get dean to do,
he was,
he was a little bit nervous I think
doing it because it's not part of his
character.
I wanted him to take the project.
I was given him,
hold it and see if I could get someone
to help me hold on the trait.
Now,
one of the things that we want to figure
out is given the maps of meaning are
going to conflict with regards to the
importance of objects including in this
notion of object including ourself and
other people.
What's the appropriate strategy to adopt
in the process of negotiation,
which is very much related to your
question.
You said,
well what constitutes say the essential
aspects of peace?
Well,
what are the things you have to figure
out is when you're in unknown territory
and you'd be put there by someone else
who's also there because of you,
what do you do?
How is it that you should act so that
you're acting optimally,
so to speak,
to resolve the problem in the most
positive of ways.
Most causative of conceivable weights,
which is to say we need to figure out a
set of rules that everyone can agree on
for operating in the domain where there
aren't any rules.
We cook a black Melvin cause I haven't
want on tape.
Yes.
Yeah.
So we know,
you know it's culture aid as this story.
Culture B has this story and they meet
as soon as they meet the members of both
cultures are no longer in these stories.
They're in some domain in between and
the rules that apply here and the rules
that apply here do not apply here.
So kind of course the question is what
rules apply here and well,
the other diagram that I'll keep showing
you,
somebody described it as the bouncing
ball,
which is kind of a good way of
describing it.
The rules that apply outside of the
domain.
Here are the rules and that constituted
the way that's the hero's path.
So you would say that
the hero,
this is interesting,
this is why you get archetipal hero
figures.
There was really the ideal figures for
culture and they're also as a general
rule,
representatives of peace,
sorry,
this is very,
very common food.
If for example,
the sort of the embodiment of pace and
the same thing is true for Christ.
It's because they are those,
their patterns of behavior characterized
the optimal form of action that is to be
undertaken in the domain.
This between two specified domains.
Um,
I guess he came into our territory and
were part of your culture.
All of that done.
I was just wondering in
general meeting,
wow,
what do you think,
what would happen if instead of just
your map again,
pin on all of us.
Um,
the police stated a crucial meeting.
Well Danielle did a toss an insult
adding mousy lab,
but this is something that you like,
I don't know how thoroughly you were
taking in by this particular
demonstration,
but one of the things that you have to
try to,
um,
appreciate is,
you know,
as,
as clearly as you can,
is just what were your responses during
the,
during the interruption,
because this was the entrance of the
stranger,
so to speak,
to hostile,
strange.
I mean,
he had his own agenda.
They weren't actually,
he wasn't really his agenda.
It was an agenda that he was acting out
for someone else.
So he's kind of in a sense just the
emissary of bad news.
But this is a PC.
This is a pretty minor example of
hierarchy disruption.
But you think,
for example,
had it mean real.
There's a,
well,
one of the things that I was told before
I came to Harvard was it,
there was a certain amount of tension
between junior and senior faculty
members.
This is not nearly as true as I was led
to believe before I got here.
And much of the distance that exists is
a function of age and,
and well in large part anyways,
but one of the things that this sort of
disruption would do the me if it really
happened,
would be to undermine my confidence in
my position here and since I have
devoted a lot of my life to attaining
this particular position,
or at least that's how it's worked out,
that sort of objectively minor
intervention could have,
you know,
all sorts of highly negative
consequences in this case though
wouldn't really have such consequences
because of what,
what really made me think that this must
be,
this must be stage taking it to
borehole.
Yeah.
Well that's okay.
Okay.
That's a good,
that's a good point.
That's part of it because I didn't,
Dean wasn't as forceful as I would've
liked to have been on.
I actually asked him to come in here
because he has natural politeness,
overcame his acting ability.
Unfortunately,
I wanted him to come in here and just
tell me what was happening,
you know,
more or less abruptly and just take it.
I was certainly,
I had made it,
made it fairly believable.
I mean that's true.
That's true.
Oh yeah.
We were all anxious,
but we're not anxious anymore because
we've redefined what it means now.
We've right.
And even before it was clear to everyone
in the room that it was staged.
Like as soon as he left,
he,
as soon as he left,
we started talking about it as an
example.
So now everyone got what they wanted it.
I mean going with his story,
he got the projector and we took the,
the event of having the projectors taken
from us to mean,
well great.
Now we have an example to talk about for
a mile.
So kind of thing was a change card sort
of rec revisionist history.
Even before I realized that,
we said as we started talking about,
I want a perfect example.
I was pretty sure it was stage because I
thought it would be highly inappropriate
for him to come.
Absolutely.
[inaudible] was the real situation.
That professor was in the lecture of 300
people and had to have this machine and
this was the only one.
I don't think that would be,
that wouldn't be an unreasonable
situation.
Well,
no,
but the what is the more appropriate,
right,
exactly right.
He should have asked me brothers,
the room or equipment.
What does this mean?
Interest.
Why do you think it took you such a long
time?
Um,
yeah,
I probably do a piece together so,
so
sorry.
Somebody else again.
Tiny.
You think it took you such a long time
to la first?
The issue was you needed,
well that was at least that was my cover
story.
I mean the real issue is what the hell
are you doing barging in here in front
of my whole class,
taking this dam project or make me look
like an idiot.
But the cover story is I need this
projector to finish my class
anyways.
That's how it work out in reality I
think.
Yes.
Okay.
We come back in.
Yeah.
I'll just call and tell him,
you know,
this,
this hoax day.
This is,
what is that?
Um,
well I don't remember.
When did you leave?
Immediately afternoon.
That was a stage that was staged.
Yeah.
Okay.
Jerry Kagan and the basement using the
overhead projector
to lecture class.
Oh,
well I asked him to come in here.
Do you have a dispute with me about the
meaning of an origin?
So
unimportant
I stage [inaudible] classic example.
That's
right.
That's right.
Back to the most appropriate fantasy.
And the fantasy being an alternative
story where the motivational
significance of things is the way that
you wish they would be
entertained by it.
Because I was actually seeing if you
would ask the same with,
you know,
that you've been telling us
and seeing if you would actually go
through like it was cool to see,
like
in real life you would have had,
it
depends how you're approached the,
if the cover story is plausible and the
emergency seems to justify,
well that's another,
and that's one of the things I've been
trying to point out to the meaning of an
event depends on the behavioral strategy
that you using the presence of the
event.
So even with Dean,
for example,
in his intervention,
it's the strategies that he used to,
uh,
to offer me the anomalous information
aren't going to determine the phenomenon
that I am in that particular context.
So if he,
like if he would've called me outside
and say,
look,
you know,
excuse me,
but here's the situation and it's a
large context situation.
You know,
like let's say Kagan needed the
projector because
he was involved at some major
fundraising episode for the,
for the department and it had broken
down suddenly,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Well then I'll basically what you're
doing under those is,
I can erase this now is
this idea,
alright,
little stories inside this is a
dominance hierarchy by the way.
He thinks a lot.
He did.
Uh,
anyways,
so what gene would have to do in order
to,
well dean would have to do in order to
convince me that his intrusion into my
story was justified.
Say My story of being at this level of
analysis cause to make would be to make
reference to a larger story of which I
was also a part that I considered as
well as him super ordinate to the things
that were going on now.
So he would say,
yes,
I know that this event has meaning a
from the frame of reference of this
ongoing class.
But from frame of Reference v,
which you also share,
it has this alternative meaning we'll
contrast the meanings and come to some
sort of agreement about them.
And I'd say,
well,
you know,
if I found his story convincing,
I'm subordinate,
I'd altered this story because it would
be less motivationally challenging then
for me to be engaged in altering the
superman story,
assuming they're shared.
So that's,
that's the kind of decisions you're
always making.
If you're negotiating with someone,
for example,
you do the same thing.
I mean,
what if I want something from you that
you don't want to give me,
I have to offer something to you that,
that is sufficiently important to
counterbalance your laws or offer you
the possibility of that in the future or
anyways.
That's okay.
Okay.
So yeah,
there were two things right after he
left.
Yeah.
Uh,
turning the [inaudible] into,
uh,
talking to beginning to talk about it as
an experiment or it changed the whole
valence of the thing,
right.
Right away.
And the humor was also a part of that
too.
It became a source of humor at the same
time.
And it was just interesting to watch
whether everyone immediately saw that it
had been a hoax or not treating it as if
it had been treating it as an
experiment,
took away all the anxiety and the
negative energy attached to it and
neutralize it and put it in this new
site.
So
that is the instant provision of a
story.
Yeah,
exactly.
Right.
And that,
that,
so you know,
that's a,
that's the classic demonstration of the
fact that the story is in fact what
makes your emotions and you're always
trying to regulate your emotions in the
face of the unknown,
so to speak.
So the,
the notion of the humor is interesting
too.
One of the mythological precursors of
the figure of the,
of the savior,
which is sort of the archetype of the
hero is the trickster shrinks.
Right?
Right,
right.
The trickster is but bugs bunny for
example,
that's his classic rule in,
in Warner brothers cartoons.
He always has a,
uh,
he always gives the events at twist
negative events of twists that make them
turn out right.
And the twist may not look exactly on
the straight and narrow window occurs.
But as the story unfolds,
it appears to be the right thing.
And trickster figures are very common
figures in mythology,
especially.
Okay.
Apparently at the stage of cultural
development where the thicker of the
hero is really being elaborated up into
something identifiable.
So he's sort of a transition figure.
An adolescent,
you might say.
In a sense.
So the irony is to see that there's an
ironic distance,
right?
I mean I'm in,
the humor is in a kind of an ironic
distance,
isn't it?
You know,
is it something that turns out to be not
what it seemed to be,
right.
I mean cause the trickster seems to be
fit.
It turns out it's that.
And so there's a kind of double meaning.
But why,
you know,
I think we also find things humorous.
When did we become spontaneously aware
that once again,
we've transcended a set of arbitrary
limitations.
So I think keywill occurs at least in
some instances when you move from a
bounded domain to outside the domain of
that back and do another one because you
have a fleeting,
you have a fleeting moment there where
you recognize your,
where are,
you recognized yourself as sort of a
transcendent figure and people find out,
well hey find that,
oh,
the word empowering springs to mind.
It's a word I particularly hate,
but
what I don't really understand is that
my feeling in the sea,
which I didn't realize until the end of
the stage,
which is great embarrassment.
You
okay?
Why were you bear?
Okay.
Why were you embarrassed for me?
See that's thoughts.
I think similar to what she said was
that instead of like we sit here and we
listen to you as a professor and you
then placed in the position of a
bickering of a boy.
Right,
right.
And just be like your credibility with
seriously on the ride.
Right,
right.
And so it was Kinda like,
yes,
you see that,
like the phenomena.
I think the phenomena of embarrassment
is one of those things that all curves
when you,
when you watch rabid movement down a
dominance hierarchy,
like you sometimes in your own case for
example,
if you feel ashamed about something,
say you turned back,
well that's because you've just
manifested a behavior which you know
full well is in very poor record with
the way you conceptualize your position
in a given Darwin,
sorry,
which basically means that you backed
and blow yourself and that makes you
self conscious and also puts you out.
The other thing that happens under those
circumstances is that like if you have
adopted a story and it protects you,
the story has certain rules that you
have to fall right.
And if you don't follow the rules,
then you immediately forfeit the
protection of the story.
So if you're like high up in the story,
so to speak,
climbing up the dominance hierarchy
that's associated with a particular
story and you pull off of behavior,
that's,
you know,
it's tricky and it works,
but it's really,
uh,
it's immoral from your own perspective
and you get self conscious and you've
also exposed yourself to the unknown
there in a big way because you've just
broken your own rules.
And the problem with writing your own
rules is your rules are what protect
you.
So it's easy to,
if that's a good trick of cell cells
from others and from,
from the unknown in general.
I mean,
no matter where it,
where it manifests itself,
right,
including inside,
inside yourself.
That's right.
Because the story that you act out is
how you ensure that you remain
predictable to yourself.
Which that's another thing that you
don't want to underestimate the
significance of this.
That what are the reasons for the shared
story is so that we don't have to have
fights about the projector and we have,
and that is dominance are determined by
dominance hierarchy.
Um,
it's also so that we don't reveal any of
our own mysteries to ourselves
unexpectedly.
It's not just to keep other people in
line.
It's also so that,
so that we can,
I think so we can tolerate looking at
ourselves in the mirror.
No,
not in any sort of horrific sense,
but just as well.
It's comforting to consider yourself
with predictable entity even when in
many,
in many ways that's an illusion.
There's because there's way more to you
than you know about and you don't
exhaust your possibilities when you're
participating in most stories.
I mean that's why if the context shifts
well,
if the context shifts,
your personality shifts because much of
what you consider your personalities,
the story you acting out,
it said like if things really fall apart
when you,
you mentioned the small possibility for
physical altercation here.
I mean you could say I would develop an
argument and then there'd be a little
physical dispute,
maybe hydrive with the projector and so
dean pull it and that would embarrass me
more and that would make me angry and
maybe I'd give it a push and he fall
over by accident.
And that would hurt them.
And that,
you know,
it's just like the whole system spirals
out of control because of this one entry
point.
And so then you say,
well you have grounds for the beginning
of a small war.
And the problem is,
is that as soon as you're outside that
the bounded domain where your emotions
are regulated and controlled,
you're literally in the grip of forces
that you poorly understanding.
This regulates your aggression,
for example,
and predict predictability.
That's,
that's implicit in shared participation
in historic.
As soon as you step out here,
it's like there's all the gods of the
unknown in a sense are waiting for you.
It's like you are now controlled by,
by anxiety.
To what degree depends on how much of
your story has been disrupted.
The same thing goes,
goes for regression and emotions under
normal circumstances you don't feel you
don't have a personality built up for
because they just,
they're not part of your environment
even though they're part of you.
So,
okay.
So the goal I guess,
of all our adaptation is to,
to have our emotions regulated,
right?
Um,
but that gets disrupted by when,
when something anomalous comes in and
there's always something anomalous.
However,
I like should we exist until the
anomalous information comes in and hits
us or because I sometimes feel myself
just going for things that I'm afraid of
just because I want like the thrill of
whatever and but that is my searching
for it and,
and dysregulating my emotions.
What are the things that sort of
complicates the idea that novelty is
threatening on first exposure is
magnitude.
It's like,
cause it's not always true is that
there's,
there's an optimal level of novelty.
Where are the magnitude of the event is
sufficiently small.
So that once activated primarily is your
incentive reward systems.
And that's the sort of thing that if
you're,
if you're operating optimally so to
speak,
you're,
you're consuming novelty at the rate
that's precisely appropriate for your
particular temperament.
That's interest.
I think when people say,
I'm following my interest or I'm
interested in this,
what they mean is there's an appropriate
amount of novelty in this,
in this area of my experiential field
and I'm feasting on it,
so to speak,
at my own rate.
But then you're aroused and while you're
optimally adapted at that point the same
because you're updating your models
about adaptation and perhaps everyone
else's as well.
Well at the same time remaining
relatively secure.
C One,
one foot.
Remember that I'll get you written.
Wait,
that's,
remember this diagram that's down the
world.
The cosmos,
it's constructed of chaos
and order.
Too much of either is debney.
Your place is right here on the line.
That's the,
that's the razor's edge,
so to speak,
a very narrow line,
halfway between chaos and order where
one is being transformed into the other
but neither predominates and that's,
there's two translations for downs.
One is the way which is the path of life
and ask the bouncing ball diagram and
the other is meaning and that's because
if you're on the path,
then your life has meaning and the
meaning is contact with novelty.
At the appropriate rate.
So it's something you feed on that's the
source of the US,
that spiritual bread.
That's what that is.
I was just,
I was just thinking about this kind of
thing the other day and,
uh,
I can't remember,
I knew exactly what contexts,
contexts,
but it seems that they're all there
instances all over our lives where there
is,
where we encountered islands here were a
novelty.
Novelty is,
uh,
actually a predictable part of our
lives.
And I think,
and what I just thought was that the
part of the administrator,
what you're talking about,
chaos there,
where's there can be a bounded region of
unpredictability.
Yeah.
So that,
you know,
everything in it so that everything in
there is unpredictable and number,
the lesson has very well defined
boundaries so that you can,
they're,
they're whole,
they're all,
there's a whole,
there are whole classes of phenomenon
that are completely unpredictable in and
of themselves.
Nonetheless,
you know what?
Right.
But nonetheless,
you know what their effects can be,
right?
You cannot be,
somebody wrote in the essay in this
class,
I believe this title in Games and Games
are new.
Example of exactly that.
They're bounded domain in which novel
events can nonetheless take place.
So if you mean when your emotional
response to novelty depends on a number
of things,
it's not,
it's not necessarily terror,
gay priority.
One of the things that hero myths tend
to point out,
cause there's sort of two classes of
romance.
There's a pyramid that describes the
successful here and there's the hero
myth that describes the unsuccessful
heroes like vehicle man.
And the unsuccessful hero is someone who
encounters the unknown accidentally.
So one of the things that transforms.
Yeah,
and he's the one who gets devoured and
never comes back.
So that's what md did this by the way,
he accidentally slept with his mother,
his mother,
she's the great mother
that seems incest.
That's the incest motif.
Now Freud read that sexually,
but really let the incest motif refers
to is the possibility of creative union
between the hero and the great mother,
which is between the explorer and the
source of all new information.
But the problem is if it's accidental,
well then it might kill you and eat it.
This blinds himself,
right?
His consciousness is destroyed because
of this accidental encounter.
And Freud,
Freud thought that was the,
like the core story that underlied the
development of humanity.
It's a very,
well,
it's a very,
depends on the level of analysis,
but if you know what that story means,
it's very,
very pessimistic.
That's it's a failed hero myth.
If you think of Freud Friday in
psychoanalysis as a form of religion,
which is,
which is a perfectly reasonable
supposition because Freud tried to
provide people with a map of meaning was
one of the few religions that I know of
where the central hero is a failure nor
success because almost all religions,
religions organized themselves around
successful heroes.
I mean,
that's why they were useful.
Substituting ordinary misery first.
Well,
it's also the case that Freud,
Freud explicitly presume that the domain
of culture associated with religion,
which is a broad domain and for which
for Freud also included literature and
art was a defense mechanism and illusion
that defense mechanism erected against
death anxiety.
It was an illusion.
One way.
That's true.
Well,
it can be true,
but it doesn't have to be true dogma.
It's true that no one serves to protect
you from the right.
Right.
Look,
there's nothing trivial about Freud's
objection and it's also the case that
people hide inside Reggie dv Ologies
precisely in order to protect themselves
from not just death,
but from the all those things they don't
understand.
But the fact that something can be true,
it doesn't necessarily mean that it is
true or that it's true in all cases.
Um,
last week you had mentioned positive
delusion and how there was a literature
that that implies healthy to have some,
was the illusion
that is being debunked at this time?
Well,
there's,
there's a big debate about it,
but,
yeah.
All right,
well just,
just thinking about,
okay,
what have you,
what if your way,
what if your path to get from,
you know,
the unbearable present to your future
goal included?
I'm thinking of the unknown or
intrusions from the unknown as lessons.
So in other words,
you were looking at them as a positive
every,
every time.
Um,
anomalous information came to you.
You said,
this has been brought to me to teach me
a lesson,
right?
We'll learn something.
And that would take the anxiety away
from it?
Well,
no,
this yeses.
Okay.
That's a perfectly interesting argument.
The last part of it,
I think,
I don't think you have to classify that
as a positive allusion.
Um,
I think that the transition in western
culture from Old Testament,
uh,
morality to do testament reality is a
transition of exactly that sort because
the message,
it's sort of implicit in the Old
Testament.
God is a pretty horrible figure.
I mean,
very powerful,
but quite frightening.
And how's it and 10 constantly displayed
in that manner.
And God,
that's new testament.
Just theoretically God love.
At least that's the attitude that you're
supposed to.
How and why is that?
Well,
it's for the reasons that you just
pointed out is the content of the time.
No one is inevitable.
The only thing you can do about it and
just change your attitude to it.
The hero myth 10 to point out that if
you approach it voluntarily,
it's the source of new information.
If you run from it,
it kills you.
Oh,
those are your options.
Your option isn't too to not happen.
If things didn't change,
there wouldn't be any light,
but you do have the option of how to
face it and it does work.
I mean if you're in getting engaged in
an argument with somebody,
like somebody that you have to argue
with and that you have to come to a
solution with,
say someone you're married to,
someone in your family,
it's like you have to solve the problem
or an or not.
You can just fight about it for the rest
of your life.
That's the other option.
Fighting about it a few times in the
rest of your life if you actually have
to address it.
Then when they present you with
anomalous information,
which is essentially like a poison
apple,
something that's an adjustable in its
present form,
your only option is to sit and think
what is there in this that I can
actually constitutes usable information
for me.
So you might say someone's objecting to
the way you conduct yourself.
Do you think that they're being hostile
and unfair but laid down some ground
rules so you more or less trust each
other?
You're only option.
There's no circumstance cause is to
remove yourself from the argument
symbolically Europe or in actuality,
is there any truth in the information
I'm getting Andy?
If so,
how?
How do I have to adjust my behavior or
my scheme of interpretation to take that
information into account?
That's presuming that what you want from
the argument is the reestablishment of
harmony and the capacity to continue to
move forward.
So that is the attitude that you,
I don't think that's a positive allusion
at all because
the way things manifest themselves is
dependent on your attitude towards them
in a nontrivial way.
It's like you in in a,
in a major way.
You determined the Valence of phenomenal
by your approach to them and we don't
know the limits of that.
Okay,
so you're saying basically then before
the hero can venture out into the
unknown,
he has to take care of the anxiety right
before he can do the exploratory
behavior?
Well,
no,
not necessarily he,
but no,
no,
I wouldn't say that because the anxiety
might accompany the exploratory
behavior.
It often does.
I would just say what,
what the hero posits this.
This goes back to your point about,
uh,
last week about how the transference and
union psychoanalysis,
what the hero has to do implicitly or
explicitly is pause at his site or what,
what the individual has to be.
We implicitly or explicitly is positive.
His identity with the hero as a
potential fat who's validity can only be
tested as a consequence of actual
action,
which is to say you have a Schema.
Some anomalous information comes in,
you have a choice,
act on it or not.
If you decide to act on what you've done
implicitly is identify with the hero.
So that's an act of faith.
And that act of faith is that despite
the way the anomalous information
appears and it's destructive context,
there's something within me that I don't
know about that will enable me to cope
with it if I make the effort.
It has to be faint because?
Because it's enormous.
You don't,
you can't know low.
Okay.
Now you made,
you made a,
uh,
when you,
when you talked about the rate of a
known being related to temperament.
Yeah.
Um,
what,
what do,
what temperament do you think the ideal
here?
What would happen?
I don't think it matters.
It doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter because,
because it's a subjective phenomenon.
It's like,
it's the same with intelligence.
You could say for someone who is
profoundly retarded,
learning how to tie their shoes might be
regarded as a heroic act and justly soul
from the perspective of morality.
And because they had to overcome what
were innumerable subjective obstacles.
So timber bent or intelligence or native
ability does it,
this is a level playing field.
It doesn't demand,
it doesn't determine that that a person
can be a hero.
However,
you might say that there are different
kinds of heroes.
There's there could be here with that
ties his shoes or the hero that brings,
um,
you know,
uh,
that,
that takes America to a different place.
Whatever the Mesoamericans do,
leave that,
that Schamens,
um,
had stronger temperaments and they were,
they were seen as basically the heroes
and you know,
they could go into there,
there,
there were more passionate and that.
So it seems to me that there is a
difference between,
I want to read you something just to
move because it's such a good design.
This is really interesting.
It's very relevant to your question
about levels of heroism,
so to speak.
Okay.
This is an Indian doctor,
doctors of cosmic cycles.
Okay.
I want you to think about with regards
to this,
to this diag riffle right now we know
already that this is a kind of a
schematic representation of a story with
all these other stories embedded within
it and they organize themselves over
time.
It's a dominance hierarchy because the
most dominant story,
so to speak,
occupies superordinate territory.
So if you're in a dominance hierarchy,
the most powerful person determines the
story that has the greatest domain.
And it is the case.
I'll read you some examples of this
suit.
That time.
The story of dominance disputes between
the gods are very,
very common,
mythological,
mythological tales about talk about the
movement towards monotheism.
For example.
The guards are,
are very often portrayed as at war and
it's the victorious God that becomes the
Supreme God.
I think that's a mythological
representation of the fact that those
processes actually occur in time on
earth.
We,
we dispute,
we dispute constantly the meaning of
things,
relative meaning of things and over
time,
at least within cultures,
we come to agreement about that.
That means that some positions when
another positions lose it.
That's a Darwinian competition of ideas,
although sometimes it's cooperatively,
cooperatively induced as well.
Anyways,
these are stories.
We know that stories too,
that when they transformed themselves,
they go through this cycle of
dissolution and reconstruction.
So you could say that if this is the
arrangement of stories at every level of
analysis,
each of these separate stories is
constantly undergoing dissolution and
reconstruction.
So that's happening all the way up the
chain.
I listen to this.
This is really interesting.
The doctrine of cosmic cycles from
India.
A complete cycle you got comprises
12,000 years.
It ends with the disillusion of her
mayor,
which is repeated more drastically.
Matt have per layer the great
disillusion at the end of the thousand
cycle for the paradigmatic Schema,
creation,
destruction,
etc. Is reproduced an infinitive.
The 12,000 years of the Bahai Yoga were
regarded as divine years each with a
duration of 360 years,
which gives a total of 4 million,
320,000 years for a single cosmic cycle.
1,000 such Matt,
how are you?
This makes up a KALPA 14 culpas makeup,
a man,
Vera.
Then Tara so named because each
Manvantara,
it's supposed to be ruled by man who's
the mythical ancestor king.
Okay,
so one of the implications of this is
that the cyclical or that
if you pick a domain of this cyclical
process,
you can ascribe its establishment to the
mythical ancestor king.
Okay?
Kaaba is equivalent to a day in the life
of Brahma,
a second cup or two a night,
a hundred of these years of Brahma.
In other words,
311 millions of human 311,000 millions
of human years constitutes the life of
Brahma.
But even this duration of the God's
life,
there's not exhaust time.
The guards are not eternal on the cosmic
creations and destruction succeed each
other forever.
So the Indian notion is that this is
kind of an infinite,
this thing is infinite and structure all
the way up as far as you can go in all
the way down as far as you can go in.
And every level of analysis,
there's these constant cycles of
creation and destruction.
That sounds almost like alchemy.
I mean it's sort of a very,
it's a way of playing messiah with the
symbols and the way that scientific
sounding way.
Yeah.
Well they know,
oh,
people had scientific intuitions prior
to the,
to the onset of science as a formal
enterprise as well as mythological
intuitions.
Oh,
this,
this dark.
Turn this off I think is obviously
representing something like this.
So
the,
uh,
you mentioned earlier that the dominance
hierarchies are this way and for some
reason that doesn't,
it doesn't make sense.
In my head,
um,
because it's,
it's,
he would seem to me that,
that they'd go,
um,
instead of going up there,
they are within each other.
So if,
if,
if Sean came in and say you have one of
the,
the three right there,
the little ones right there.
You,
you both had,
uh,
a story there,
but he,
he gave you a bigger story.
Yeah.
Then that would change.
That would change yours instead of
looking at it as going up there,
I would look at it as judged as being
different and he has to give you one
that incumbent.
Yeah,
but,
but I would say that's a more dominant
story.
It contains more territory.
It rules more territory.
That's,
that's the notion.
Literally it rules more territory.
So I'd be willing to subordinate my
story to this large,
the largest story,
say for the Mesopotamians that's ruled
by Martech.
So you see there's a real neat twist in
this.
I think it's really something else.
So it's like you have a real paradox is
that you need known territory to protect
yourself from chaos.
But the problem with that is known
territory has,
it has real disadvantages,
right?
It gets rigid.
That's one thing.
And it makes you have conflicts with
other people who have no territories
that are different,
different way the Mesopotamians solve.
This was by saying that the thing that
makes the superordinate story,
which is Marta,
is actually the process that transforms
all stories,
right?
So they put a paradoxical loop into this
process I suppose.
Absolutely brilliant,
brilliant.
We say,
well,
all your,
all your conditional stories have to be
dependent,
have to always remain dependent on your
ultimate subordination,
to the process by which all conditionals
towards from generate.
So that's an amazing idea.
So,
so I,
I don't understand how can,
okay,
so,
so I understand that,
that the bigger the territory that the
more topical the story,
but how can on on the level where they,
where they don't come from the same
territory,
how can one be above another graphic
way?
It's not obvious up in terms of power.
We're talking about an abstract,
right?
So is it power?
So like the bottom one is,
is lower and louder than the top line.
Yes.
The middle one is lower in power,
then the outside one it goes from,
it goes from in to out.
Yeah.
No,
that's right.
And I know when we were talking about,
here's an example,
you're working for a corporation.
You're not the chief executive officer,
you're a vice president.
Okay.
This is your store.
There's three vice presidents.
There's one chief executive officer.
Okay.
You're going to be concerned.
One of your domains of concern is the
viability of your position and
everything that it's like in,
cause you're also the head of a whole
whole set of other subordinates who are
beneath you,
so to speak.
So that's your particular domain of
concern.
But it would be rational,
so to speak,
under most conditions to subordinate
your desire to maintain this territory
in favor of maintaining the entire
territory.
Yes.
Whenever there's a conflict,
I mean generally speaking you could
envision perhaps some cases where that
wouldn't be,
Hey John ain't sure I understand.
Okay.
So my question is really do the vibe and
do the vice presidents,
is there a hierarchy amongst amongst
them?
You mean this way?
Yeah,
yeah,
that's what I'm asking.
I'm asking.
Oh,
um,
well there would be,
if there
isn't that there would be,
if they were ever engaged in a task that
would require them to arrange
themselves.
I mean like,
I'm not,
I'm not reading this and this isn't a
fixed picture of like there's not
necessarily three of these subs subs if
you place in that way.
Does that mean that it's possible in a
dominant is hard for them to be relative
to quality of position?
Um,
although that I think that would
necessarily break down those,
say if there's three vice presidents,
they have to organize themselves to do a
job.
There's going to be a,
a dominance hierarchy that actually is
hierarchical emerge in the course of
their cooperation or another story.
That's right.
They no tied into it.
Not your story.
It's also the case that like your
position in the dormant attire,
he shifts across stories.
You know,
it's like,
well,
you might be a senior at Harvard and you
know,
so that you're at the top of,
of at least one part of dog's hierarchy
there.
But then when you go on the workforce,
it's like whack.
You're at the bottom of another
dominance hierarchy or you can just
shift in and out of them during the day.
And that's partly because we've been
able to abstract or dominance
hierarchies up to such a degree that you
could participate in and innumerable
some of them even a symbolic coming,
you can change the valence of a
phenomena just by shifting your
reference point.
Nope.
Say It depends on what you contrast it
with.
I can say in the big picture of things,
right.
That's the big picture.
Exactly.
Take the big,
something terrible happens to you.
I take the big picture so the picture is
too big,
then everything becomes worthless.
What's the button?
This goes back a little ways to what you
said about,
um,
when anomalous information is promising
as opposed to threat.
Yeah.
Um,
and it sounded like you were saying that
it relates to the feelings of advocacy
of the hero or of the confront her.
Yeah.
Uh,
would you describe it as an act of
faith?
Yeah,
just curious about that.
I mean,
um,
what creates,
I mean is that what you did you mean to
say feelings of personal efficacy?
Okay.
You mean instead of an act of faith?
Well or how,
how would you relate that to I guess
what I'm trying to say that if you,
if you undertake to voluntarily,
if you undertake to voluntarily expose
yourself to an aspect of the unknown
that is an act of faith.
And whether you know it or not,
you are emulating this heroic model.
So one of the things that young
attempted to point out was that since
you're doing that,
you might as well know it because as
soon as you don't,
then you have access to this incredible
wealth of information but sort of
details the structure of that process
and that it can provide you with more
explicit knowledge about what it might
mean saying cause you're,
if you say,
boy,
I wrote down,
when I think of the history as the
historical historical a hypothesis.
Let me see if I can find,
can we ask revolutions in procedure
bring about revolutions and experience.
That's the hypothesis of historical man
fundamentally.
Which is to say that
you can pause it,
that through your actions you can
transform your environment.
That's an act of faith and it's the act
of faith that precedes the construction
of culture.
Because by doing that,
what you are saying is that the
individual,
despite the immense power of balance
that appears between the individual and
not knowing the individual is in fact
part of the process.
It's of equal magnitude.
Equal side.
Remember I showed you these pictures?
Let's see.
Yeah,
this is a good one.
Look.
Okay.
Yeah,
I know.
Sweet.
Anyways,
you know,
I would regard,
this is pre Columbian.
I would return this as an image
constrict constructed by the member of a
culture for whom the hypothesis that the
individual was equivalent potency in
comparison with the great mother or as
as not true or just barely dawning on
consciousness is there as the hero.
I mean there's a huge difference in
terms of perceived relative power.
And then you see,
well here this is a much more modern
issue.
You see,
there's much more uh,
indication of equality by this point.
Yeah.
So the notion of the divine individual
like that's,
that's the,
that's what I think.
I think that idea,
it's mythological idea cause it has to
do with meaning.
That's at the core of the democratic
notion that everybody is equal before
the law,
which is has its roots in the idea that
everyone is equal before God,
but what that means by,
well by equal,
what equal means is that
your capacity for heroism is not limited
by your native abilities,
which I think is really interesting
because it's very difficult for us to
think of anything that you can do for
that.
There really is an equal playing field
for it.
Like most things are dependent say on
your intelligence that's heritable to at
least a substantial degree or your
physical ability or your gender,
your race or these things that are
really built in,
but your capacity to face things that
are anomalous,
that's really a part of your character.
I think that's,
that's above,
above those biological constraints in a
way because what's anomalous to you is
very much dependent on your personal
nature.
So you get the,
you get problems that are exactly the
same size that you are.
So that's,
that's another part of the reason why
you get this weird notion of equality
before God.
I wrote a story about that later in the
manuscript to try to make that clear in
this story.
I met this woman when I was a behavior
therapist and this was a devastated
woman.
I mean she had every problem that you
could imagine essentially and then a
bunch more.
She,
uh,
she was so pathologically shy,
but she could not look at anybody that
she thought was up higher.
The dominants are not meant anybody.
I mean,
literally she was at the block and when
she approached people say,
who are doing therapy in this one unit?
She'd go like this,
just like in just like an arcade figure
approaching an amperage.
She couldn't bear to look at the person.
And part of the behavioral treatment was
to help her stop doing this because we
should do it in public as well.
And of course,
people who act oddly in public tend to
have a log social troubles.
So we were hoping to get rid of this
particular symptom,
but she was also,
uh,
she,
she was not an intelligent person by any
stretch of the imagination.
She probably had an Iq.
So we're in the neighborhood of 70,
which is about two standard deviations
below the mean or about four standard
deviations below the average in this
route.
So like she,
she's not a smart person unless you've
tested people with Iq tests,
you really have no idea how much
difference there is,
how much difference four standard
deviations means.
It means a lot.
Uh,
she had very poor personal hygiene and
because I think probably because she was
raised as badly as you could possibly be
raised.
Um,
um,
she wasn't particularly attractive as a
person either.
She was,
she was,
uh,
oh,
okay.
What else?
Well,
her boyfriend was at schizophrenia and
he was also an alcoholic and he was
violent and he is to accuse her of being
possessed by the devil.
And he theater.
She lived with her mother who was like
old and sick and an aunt who was
bedridden and they were on welfare and
she had no education to speak.
I've been really no hope for a job.
Like when I saw her,
she's probably close to 40.
Um,
anyways,
like this woman,
the cards were stacked against her,
you know,
in every way you could possibly imagine.
But what her primary,
this was interesting.
They will,
her primary concern in therapy was not
really what could be done for her.
Like she'd gone through behavioral
treatment kind of work temporarily,
but she reverted to her old habits very,
very,
very soon.
What she really wanted from me was to
help her sort of make a dent in the,
she was an outpatient in the hospital
administration so that she could find an
inpatient and these like the inpatients
that are left in mental hospitals now,
these people are seriously troubled
because anybody that could possibly be
let out has been let out.
So like I used to go into the basement
at the Douglas Hospital in Montreal and
it was like,
it was like something out of Dante's
inferno.
It was an old building and the people,
like there was a coke room in the
basement and the people that were in
there were just,
well,
you know those mini,
you know,
the medieval paintings of,
of disfigured people that were in
common.
Well,
that's what it was like down there.
And that's what most of the inpatients
were like.
They're just,
they were just totally destroyed.
And some of them had been that way for
like 30 years.
So anyways,
what she wanted was not help for her.
And she didn't come in to complain about
her situation,
even though there was lots of reasoning
can play about,
she wanted to find somebody in the
hospital grounds that she could take out
for walks.
So yeah.
And she had dog that she used to take
care of,
you know,
it out for walks.
And she was,
I thought she was remarkable this
person,
because
from the deterministic standpoint,
so to speak,
there's no reason at all that she should
have been anything but the hostile and
bidder.
But her problems for whatever reasons,
we're not,
we're not her primary focus of concern.
And,
uh,
well I thought that was just a good
example of how,
you know,
regardless of your particular
circumstances,
it is possible that you might make the
right choices.
So,
and that that's maybe not dependent on
things that you might consider
biological givens.
So,
and then I do think it's true that the
burrata your talents,
the bigger your responsibility.
So that's how things work out just
because,
well,
that's one way you can make sense of the
theoretical lead unequal distribution of
talents.
The more talent,
the more responsibility simplest still.
All right.
I guess I asked that because really
you're,
it sounded as if we were describing,
uh,
the non threat,
the promising anomalous as occurring
sort of within a space that was,
you could define a space within which
like in a game of space within which the
anomalous occurs and it's safe.
Yeah.
Well we do,
but this is an account in which it's
more in the self,
um,
yeah,
that was able to deal with the anomalous
wherever it occurred.
Right,
right.
No,
that,
that's a perfectly reasonable contrast.
I mean,
when we play,
that is what we're doing.
The first thing you,
we're carving out a defined space.
We say,
look,
here's the actual borders within this,
we will allow a certain amount of
anomaly to occur so that we can practice
coping with the anomaly.
People like that.
They like watching games for example.
Right.
That's,
that's why kids play games as well.
It's like kids,
you know,
if you watch them,
if they're eight or nine years old to
get together in the playground,
they'll say,
well,
here's the rules.
Black,
black lab that defines the territory's,
right.
Well the rules are just enough to get to
get something going so that someone
normally can occur at formal games are
like that evening.
And it is often difficult to distinguish
when it is that you're not playing a
game anymore.
I mean,
some people play games their whole lives
formally.
A lot of the things we do as academics
ideologically are abstracted games,
that's for sure.
But there is a difference between that
and the general sense that if a normally
arises,
I incapable of dealing with it.
Yeah,
and that's,
that's the more,
well,
they're both,
they're both hero types.
I mean sports heroes or heroes,
right?
The ritual models for emulation,
they deal with anomaly and bounded
circumstances.
I would say there,
there paragons of normal adaptation.
That's right.
They master a bounded domain.
They're not necessarily mastery.
The transition between domains,
that's,
that's a different type of heroism
but it's still a form of heroes.
Are you saying that the greater your
biological gift,
you say the bigger your responsibility,
do you mean the bigger your
responsibility to go out and encounter
and bring it back?
I would say
well there's more.
That's right.
That's part of it.
Right off the backs.
Like what you don't know is differing in
contrast to what you know.
So the structure of what you know and
its and its size,
so to speak is,
is a proportionate innocence to the kind
of unknowns that you'll encounter.
Like in a sense
I read it say,
I don't remember where that one of the
hallmarks of genius is the capacity to
see mystery where others only see.
So you won't even see the same things
with variance and capacity comes very
innocent perception.
So,
and then I would say adapt.
Is it?
So like
coping with coping with the stresses of
a about well-run household might be
sufficient challenge for a given person.
I mean,
in reality,
I mean they may do a very good job of
that and that's at the limits of their
ability.
And when you meet someone like that,
you regard them as admirable sort of
intrinsically for someone whose talents
are greater,
their field of,
of conflict has to be greater,
otherwise they're not.
They're putting artificial limitations
on their,
on their development and all that unused
talent down.
Just work against them.
You know,
there's nothing worse than a neurotic
intellectual cause.
The neurotic intellectual is,
it's incredibly devious even to
themselves.
I mean,
if you're dealing with someone in
therapy,
an Iq of 130 say,
and they'd be telling themselves lies
for 25 years and these lies are,
are unbelievably coherent and convincing
because they've used all that
intellectual talent too to erect this
thing that's really going to devour
them.
So,
so then you've made a,
you separated.
Okay.
So there's a lot of time.
It's from the right hemisphere and the
left hemisphere is,
produces the,
the pleasing sensations in the unknown
and the Right Hemisphere,
the fearful lens.
Well,
you've also separately the dimension of,
um,
it's not related to in the left
hemisphere of the ability to organize,
et Cetera,
and then the in the right hemisphere.
Can you tell there's this,
I think there's a certain amount of,
of,
I don't know exactly how it
thank you.
Social personalities have,
uh,
or you know,
people who are in prisons or whatever,
they have generally low intelligence and
uh,
but also,
stimulated very easily by,
by thing.
Well,
that's one,
that's one line of theorizing.
Yeah.
There's,
there's more to the story than like
Tamar men alone doesn't,
I don't think temperament alone is
enough to make you conduct disorder anti
social.
I mean,
I would say that among like every
temperamental tight has its own,
has the kind of pathology gets most
prone to like,
if you're really inhibited,
you'd likely to develop anxiety
disorders.
Like that's your sphere of weakness.
Like everybody has the sin towards which
they're most,
uh,
they're most attracted so to speak.
But I think under very few
circumstances,
could you say that temperament was
destiny and even then if temperament is
destiny,
can you say,
well,
the story that someone's participating
in you isn't going sequence of
biological forces.
I would say then that the morality of
that person is still can only be
calculated by looking at how they dealt
with what they were particularly,
particularly given.
I kind of,
I had a friend for example,
when I grew up who had an extensive
family history of alcoholism.
It's like went back at least three
generations are affected a lot of his
male relatives and by the time he was 14
he was alcoholic and I would say,
well,
how do you judge someone like that?
Well,
I mean you want you say is that there
was much more temptation there,
so how he dealt with it,
that was his particular province and it
didn't work out very well for him.
But I guess what I'm trying to say is
that,
well it's the Senate.
Same thing I was trying to say with that
story about the woman at the hospital is
that,
you know,
you're handed up your hand,
didn't know rang of problems that are
unique.
Some of those problems are biologically
determined.
The manner in which you approached them
determines the integrity of your
character.
It's hard to judge that from outside.
And I think that's another reason why
in,
in various religious traditions,
there's the notion that the only
accurate judgment can come after your
death,
for example,
that you know,
you have to be judged by a trans,
something of transcend the door edge and
for it to be accurate.
So,
but it would seem like you said,
of of his person and the 70 at Yosemite,
that intelligence could help them to
face,
to develop a better story.
Well,
consider it depends.
It depends on your,
it depends on what you mean by better.
I mean that's the,
that's the issue.
More debt.
Well,
I don't know.
It's like if you,
if you're a smarter,
you have bigger problems there could've
just made it more bitter.
I mean,
she was at this dad's postures at this
point,
willing to satisfy herself just by
helping someone who was lower down the
issue.
Right.
But she was more intelligent.
It might have just met her.
At least it's conceivable that would be
the case.
I mean for you,
I mean you could look at this on a
broader evolutionary scale and say,
well,
like our intelligence,
does that make our life better?
Well,
I would say,
well it's a toss up because on the one
hand,
well here we sit and everything's
perfect.
On the other hand we've invented the
atom bomb and like it's only been 40
years and we don't know whether the fact
that here we sit and everything's
wonderful is sufficient to
counterbalance the fact that using the
same intelligence,
we've also created this massive
weaponry,
which,
which is still around and will always be
around to pretty much bring things to an
end.
So intelligence is a moral,
that's my,
that's my take lines.
Like you can,
you can use it one way or another and it
broadens your domain of action,
but there's nothing intrinsically good
about it.
It's a tool.
And it's not related to temporary.
Well,
I don't know if it's related temperament
or no.
Does this relate to like the dualism and
the bureau move to the hero has a divine
parents with the hero also comes from
humble?
Yes.
Often.
Sort of like from unexpected places.
Absolutely.
It's the same idea and it's the same
notion that couldn't give Christianity.
There's the notion of an eternal Christ
and Christ that's,
it has a historical moment and what that
idea is trying to portray is the notion
that the hero is that transpersonal
force,
so to speak.
It's a constituent element of the
psyche.
It's eternal because it's always
regenerated,
but at the same time it's perfectly
reasonable to view that eternal thing as
something that's also necessarily exist
within a specific set of constraints.
And I would say that could not exist
without that set of constraints,
which is something that will also deal
with more of the latter half of the man
of the chorus,
the manuscripts,
the constraints,
not only our constraints,
but they define the capability for
action.
Sorry,
I was talking with someone the other day
and they said,
well,
if everything was orderly,
there'd be nothing left to do.
And that's well that's the same sort of
notion that Dostoyevsky describes when
he points out that if we established a
political utopia where everything was
predictable basically in perfect,
the first thing that people would do
would be to drive themselves crazy just
so that something unexpected could
happen.
And so in literal truth that life could
go on.
So anyways,
this is,
this is something that's really useful
to consider and we will get into it
because one of the questions that people
always pose is why is it the terrible
things have to happen?
And I,
you know what the myth basically
suggests that well
for there to be something,
there has to be a division between the
limited domain in an unlimited demand.
There has to be,
it's a precondition for existence.
So then the question is,
if the existence of limitation is a
necessary precondition for existence,
is it justifiable?
And you know,
that's the big question.
Ask The big question
if limitation is a precondition for
experience is limitation justify.
And I would say what these mythological
stories are trying to do is to tell you
the story about how it could be that
limitation might be rendered bearable.
If it's,
say it's a precondition for experience.
Well this is like for me,
this is something really worth knowing
because that's a big question for
people,
especially when something really
traumatic happens.
It's like,
why?
How can I make sense out of this?
Or isn't this event so terrible that it
undermines the utility of any possible
story I could tell myself,
oh,
that's what happens when someone close
to you dies.
You know,
this is such a,
this is such a catastrophe that
everything in,
in the line of this is evidently few
tile.
Well that's,
you know,
that's sort of the bottom line of
questions.
Can you make sense out of that?
So
other questions?
Okay.
Wow.
Well that's probably good enough for
today.
I will put your papers outside my office
on,
there's a little black bench there.
Um,
every paper will have a sheet attached
to it that has detailed comments and the
grade and I hope it will be there.
Don't come until Friday morning to see
it.
It'll be there Friday.
Okay.